mack king has been a staple on the las
vegas strip for more than two decades
and he now offers a family-friendly show
in the afternoon
at the excalibur let's welcome back to
the show it's matt king welcome back hey
man thank you so much for having me i'm
excited to be here i'm excited to be
live back doing magic shows
and uh this is fantastic being in the
studio this is great having you here
again so what can we expect at the
afternoon show what do you got going on
well it's mostly a cooking show yeah
cooking demos no i'm doing magic tricks
and uh you know
same same stuff uh as before i mean it's
my wife is so excited for me to be back
to work did you get me out of the house
did you meet your wife
did you meet her at one of your shows
yeah she was about you or you got a good
memory
uh yeah she was volunteer from the
audience in a show i uh i had her pick a
card and then it came out of my pants
okay and then she was mine now did she
know she was volunteering to be your
wife whether it starts
actually volunteering to do a magic
trick the progression was
a volunteer roommate white
i think now i feel like um every time
you come on the show your pockets are
loaded like you're saying
you want to see it you're ready to go
point to a pocket let's go to this
pocket all right good right here all
right
uh yeah this is you can take a look at
that okay just like you would find in
your bedroom
mm-hmm he knows me well all right
uh so it's got two ends and a middle
yeah and uh
let's see you take the scissors okay cut
the rope in the middle there's a sharp
these are not very
sharp yeah very sharp those are because
did you cut your finger once with
scissors i have to cut myself pretty bad
okay yeah hold on to that and you cut oh
i didn't that's not even close to
exactly yeah
we can make it right though that's
pretty good that's pretty easy okay
uh i'll start over it has two ends
so that's oh mercedes is over there
mercedes
keep your eye on this end of the rope
you watch this in you guys at home
uh you're all watching this end over
here keep your eye over here wait
wait what no this wait i'll start over
two ends in the middle cut this rope why
not all right all right
all right all right uh these are the
ends but they come right off
i don't know
you put no one knows where the center is
until you put the ends back
i don't know what you want to look at
but there it goes right back in the
middle
what how do you do this all right i have
secret powers no it's the suit
i would cut it once it's non-stop
all right that's the end uh we'll start
over all right do this when you get do
you do this when you get a haircut it
goes back on comes back off goes back on
man i wish i could put something back on
yeah more pockets right
okay yeah i thought we were out i
thought we were out no we got plenty of
time we
we'll bump jeopardy and keep going oh
we'll bump jeopardy yeah all right
all right uh this is great afternoon
show one and three o'clock tuesdays
through sunday excalibur tuesday through
saturday
watch sundays and months you gotta rest
boys it's sunday stay arrested it is
for a fellow like me yeah think of
anyone you see any card yeah don't oh no
don't touch it dude
these are all different i'll show them
here uh think of one you see okay
you got it don't say it because you
actually saw it in there
deeply into my eyes uh your car was
spayed right
yeah i know and uh let's see uh make
sure i know what i'm doing
that's nice it was in fact
uh the uh now it was in fact
the uh six of spades uh no no what'd you
get uh ace of spades
you look the ace of spades that's the
most obvious card in the description
that's the one you took there's no ace
of spades in this deck dude there's not
there's not an ace of spades this is the
car this is how i met my wife i unzipped
my pants her card was in there
i don't know it's the ace's face
i can't believe it matt king thank you
so much for joining us the mac
king comedy show or matt comedy magic
show excalibur hotel casino tuesday
through saturday
1 and 3 p.m check out his social media
matt king show
that's amazing thank you my friend hey
man thanks